die eine große frage ist versammelt sich
jetzt nur die cdu hinter armin laschet
oder auch die csu die gesamte union wie
sieht es in münchen aus und dazu weiß
unser bild politik chef jan schäfer mehr
was hörst du gerade aus münchen was
hörst du aus dem süden team
wir hören und auch der kollege ralf
schuler unter anderem das offenbar
markus söder bereit ist das votum des
bundesvorstands zu akzeptieren
er hat es ja gestern auch angedeutet als
er vor die presse trat und kurz vor 14
uhr montagnachmittag und hat ja gesagt
das was heute abend im bundesvorstand
der cdu beschlossen wird und das werde
er akzeptieren auch ohne groll
also mit anderen worten da hat er sich
ein türchen offen gehalten oder
aufgemacht auch ein bisschen die hand
gereicht ein bisschen demut vor der cdu
vor dem gremium gezeigt und das so wie
wir hören wird jetzt dazu führen dass er
um 13 uhr
dieses ergebnis akzeptiert es gibt
einige im cdu-vorstand die gestern auch
diesen schritt von markus söder als
fehler bezeichnet haben als
strategischen fehler gesagt haben damit
öffnet er tor und tür für armin laschet
jetzt doch relativ reibungslos
kanzlerkandidat werden zu können genau
das tritt jetzt mutmaßlich eine also
jetzt drei stunden vor der
pressekonferenz bei wild life die
erkenntnis markus söder möchte dieses
ergebnis anerkennen zieht damit also
auch seine kandidatur heute mittag
wahrscheinlich zurück und der weg ist
frei für armin laschet
dieser ganze krimi hat ein ende als sie
tat was ich jetzt gerade gehört habe von
jemandem der da im führungszirkel der
csu ist naja das ergebnis ist ja
eindeutig also auch das deutet jetzt
darauf hin dass man sich offenbar in
münchen darauf einrichtet mit armin
laschet jetzt in den bundestagswahlkampf
zu ziehen das wird er mutmaßlich um 13
uhr dann auch so bekannte schule hatte
es gesagt die beiden gremien müssen dann
dem ganzen noch zustimmen ist das dann
nur noch etwas formelles oder sehen wir
hier dann doch gleich an einem anderen
schauplatz vielleicht nochmal diskussion
nun das für die zuschauer vor allem klar
zu machen ist dieser krimi jetzt mit
dieser entscheidung zumindest beendet
und alles danach wird relativ einfach
oder kann es noch mal die verlängerung
trotzdem geben auch wenn markus söder
das jetzt anerkennt wir haben ja gestern
auch erlebt die gremien sind eigentlich
sehr
der führungstroika in der cdu und der
csu es ist eher die basis die rebelliert
aber die gremien sind eigentlich die
instrumente die der raum in dem
umgesetzt wird was die führung richtig
verlangt im von daher erwarte ich nicht
dass die geringen sich dann noch mal
anders äußern werden interessanten das
hat ja professor oder gerade eben auch
noch mal gesagt ist was passiert mit bei
den mitgliedern was passiert bei denen
die eigentlich in den wahlkampf raus
müssen die dann bei wind und wetter an
den wahlkampfständen stehen müssen um
wahlkampf für die cdu die csu zu machen
die plakate kleben ist also die sich
richtig engagieren müssen in ihrer
freizeit damit armin laschet dann
bundeskanzler werden kann haben die lust
haben die die motivation fühlen die sich
eigentlich richtig ernst genommen jetzt
durch das was wir seit wochen eher
gesehen und was wir auch heute nacht ja
wieder erlebt haben also sind die der
meinung das ist wirklich noch meine
partei der ich hundertprozentig stehen
kann oder fühlte sich auf deutsch gesagt
verarscht eine frage noch entschuldigen
paar und zwar heute um 15 uhr
fraktionssitzung der union ist es dann
also schon kein thema mehr kann man sich
auf andere dinge konzentrieren die muss
man sich den heutigen tag nach dieser
woche vorstellen
wenn markus söder um 13 uhr dann
aufgetreten ist also wenn markus söder
auftritt um 13 und dieses ergebnis was
es gestern im bundesvorstand der cdu gab
an erkennt dann fällt es mir schwer zu
glauben dass eine fraktion wie die csu
cdu csu fraktion dann nochmal ein
aufstand proben möchte und wird ich
glaube das nicht
dann aber noch einmal also wenn wir
jetzt erleben dass tatsächlich markus
söder das ergebnis akzeptiert denn ich
glaube tief im innern brodelt es bei ihm
ich glaube der marcussen vulkan in
diesem moment denn er hat natürlich
mitverfolgt was dort im in dem vorstand
gesagt wurde über armin laschet und ich
glaube er teilt viele dieser meinung
hinsichtlich der wahlerfolge der union
ist das wirklich dann glaubwürdig und
wie muss das aussehen braucht es jetzt
einen nürnberger oder ein aachener
frühstück was braucht es um zumindest
deutschland zu zeigen ja wenn man das
ernst die frage ist ob sie es wirklich
ernst machen aber sie brauchen doch
jetzt irgendwie ein symbol der
geschlossen hat absolut richtig es gab
natürlich etwas es gab eine berlin
sitzung in der nacht von sonntag auf
montag bis um 1 uhr 30 in dieser sitzung
ging es nicht immer richtig
freundschaftlich und friedlich zu aber
das war natürlich diese sitzung in der
die weichen gestellt wurden für das was
wir jetzt erleben und mut man sich auch
um 13 uhr aber du hast vollkommen recht
es ist schon auch wieder bezeichnet dass
markus söder und jetzt flug und co2
ausstoß hin oder her dass in münchen
machen will und nicht gemeinsam mit
armin laschet dass er also offenbar in
mit von münchen aus armin laschet dann
auch zu seinem votum gratulieren möchte
und sagen möchte lieber arme und jetzt
gehen wir geschlossen zusammen vor das
signal ist nicht geschlossenheit
es wäre in der tat besser wenn sich
beide zusammen stellen würden so wie es
auch angela merkel und edmund stoiber
jahr 2002 gemacht haben uns schnell an
angela merkel unterschiedliche
charaktere würde ich sage im vergleich
natürlich zur ami laschet und markus
söder
was glaubst du was wird markus söder
jetzt die nächsten wochen die nächsten
monate und vor allem dann im wahlkampf
wirklich tun also wenn man sich das
anhört wie in der csu auch über armin
laschet geredet wurde
das kann man sich doch kaum vorstellen
dass da jetzt irgend wie die truppen
gesammelt werden und gesagt wird okay
wir plakatieren jetzt bayern zu mit
armin laschet plakaten okay da würde
ohnehin markus söder oder wer auch immer
von der csu der landesliste dann der
bundestagsliste auf platz 1 stehen
wie siehst du das ich glaub wir werden
in dem bei kampf nur wenig armin laschet
plakate sehen wie noch nie zuvor in
einem bundestagswahl kann angela mehr
hören oder ihres kandidaten nein im
zweifel in münchen oder in bayern wird
natürlich dann markus söder ganz fett
plakatiert obwohl er gar nicht antritt
aber das ist ja haben wir auch schon bei
europawahlen erlebt dass angela merkel
plakatiert wurde obwohl die gar nicht
zur debatte und zur wahl stand also das
wird es ging es wird sicherlich viele
kandidaten geben die sich selbst
plakatieren mehr als es früher der fall
gewesen ist
sprach's jahren in armin laschet den
markus söder brodelt ist das ist ein
vulkan der auch immer wieder ausbricht
ich glaube dass er als politisches
alphatier auch gut beraten ist und das
weiß er selbst am ende kurz vor der wahl
auf jeden fall still zu halten denn
nichts ist schlimmer als wenn man nach
der wahl gesagt bekommt ja wir haben
verloren und zwar wegen dir mein lieber
markus söder deine ganz
querschläge die haben dazu geführt dass
wir nicht als einheit aufgetreten sind
sondern als zerstrittene partei markus
schlau genug sein den mund zu halten
ruhe zu geben aber 18 uhr am 26
september
das wird genau seine uhrzeit sein dann
wird er sagen
dieses ergebnis habe ich so
vorhergesehen armin laschet wenn es dann
so kommt muss man natürlich sagen aber
wenn die union stellt absteigen sollte
dann ist genau der 26 september 18 uhr
danach die zeit rache tag für markus